the return of kindness 101 with Steve
Hartman it's our Series where he and his
kids Marilyn Emmett shares special
stories of kindness and of character
here's a look at what they've got coming
up
[Music]
today's class is about honesty there's
even studies showing that parents lie
I've never seen such a study
have you sold any toffee tactics to my
grandmother
you'll never forget that rock not as
long as I live if I'm ever locked up in
Alcatraz I know who I want myself with
me
it is up anytime to you we're here for
you
and you don't oh
thank you for joining us I really
appreciate it thank you for inviting us
and don't forget to stay kind
[Music]
stay kind and more good news Emmett and
Meryl have taken a trip from the
kindness 101 headquarters and pay the
Hartman residents to be here with us in
Times Square and they've brought the
special kindness 101. hey welcome Emmett
welcome both of you uh this is great we
got a new season and you're sticking
with your dad on this one I Emmett first
question to you what's your favorite
part about doing this with Steve so I
feel like all of us need to be a little
bit more kind and Steve has really I
feel like instilled that uh in all of us
well I call them Steve
okay okay Dad dad I guess uh but I feel
like he's even taught me and Meryl to be
a little more kind has he yeah how so uh
well you guys both struck me as being
kind kids anyway but what has he taught
you uh I feel like the lessons that he
teaches I mean some of this stuff is
really uh has been new to us it's been
as much of a learning experience for us
as anyone else I feel like and Meryl I
understand you've had to extend some
kindness to your father when you caught
him in a bit of a lie could you tell us
about this one of the lessons is about
honesty yes yes yeah so we were talking
about honesty and he we said something
and he said well and Emmett said well
there's even studies that parents lie to
their kids and I was like oh isn't that
so
what is he lying about he was like he
stole something from the candy drawer
is it candy yeah
but he didn't want
it so I just said I'll I won't say
anything about this and then I caught
him and then we had a lesson I busted
his dad yes how'd you bust him
well
I'm like what
what road God and he said no it wasn't
possible I like Meryl how you always end
all the segments with stay kind yes
that's that's really one of my favorite
parts of the segment that you all do why
do you think that's so important I think
that even whether people realize it or
not
that's bringing them a different feeling
that they aren't going to find anywhere
else and that it can really change what
they do and what they think and
it makes them feel good if they do
something kind yep it really does and
Emma you guys are like celebrities
people spot you on the street yeah and
they're like hey it's eminent Merrell
yeah what does that feel like uh I mean
for my whole life I've watched my dad
get spotted on the street and I feel
like it's nice to note that uh kindness
101 is actually like making an impact
yes yeah it really is uh it kind of 101
it's back with a new season uh it is the
Emmett and uh Merrill Hartman show with
sidekick Steve Hartman yeah Steve is on
the road right now yeah but we're glad
you guys it returns next week thank you
so much for being here thank you thank
you it's lovely